let's jump to the story we got this uh
we got the story from Luke gradkowski
over here on Twitter at Luke we are
changed as the emails here are very
revealing as the White House was
lobbying to censor Tucker Carlson and
Tommy Lauren on Facebook so Attorney
General Andrew Bailey of Louisiana says
we now have hard evidence that President
Biden's Administration colluded with
social media companies to censor
differing viewpoints and silence quote
misinformation that was later deemed
true
here's the White House employee asked
Twitter to silence Robert Kennedy Jr
here at the Biden White House directs
Facebook to shut down conservative
voices Tucker Carlson and Tommy Loren
and uh more here's the collusion etc etc
I'm kind of I'm kind of surprised I mean
Tucker Carlson's a big name this is this
is a big risk for them Tucker these guys
got money yeah no audacity of them to
try to censor hey [ __ ] when I think
the first when I think of the word
conservatism republicanism uh the first
word the first faced parts of my face is
Coca-Cola right yeah I used to face some
Fox News when I when I when I think of
Fox News I think of him he's the biggest
most popular news anchor out there and
for the White House to say no we need to
silence him we need to ban him that's a
that's a huge ask that of course
Facebook couldn't officially comply with
but this is this is the documents we're
getting from the Attorney General of
Louisiana that of course is requesting a
lot of these documents this is what
they're making public what aren't they
making public and if the White House is
asking for Tucker Carlson to be taken
down I mean I mean what does that leave
us with I I imagine everyone else I I
think they're they're seeing what they
could get away with I think with these
emails they're like let's just go as far
as we can let's eliminate all voices and
I think Facebook here clearly said hey
we can't go too crazy now we'll give you
almost everything you want but but we
won't give you this and I think this is
a way of also negotiating as well you
always ask for the biggest prize and
then you meet halfway oh we can't get uh
Tucker Carlson oh but we could get uh
Alex Jones or we could get David Ike
let's get those guys okay fine we got it
right and they still uh destroyed Free
Speech because this is essentially
trampling on the first amendment in so
many different different instances and a
clear violation of the law clear abuse
of power and this is what they do in
third world countries this is what they
do in dictatorships so to have this
happen here in America it should be a
big wake-up call to everyone especially
with how much power uh the Democrats are
consolidating for themselves which
they're clearly using against their
political opponents and not against any
kind of legitimate uh you know a bad guy
out there right and he's the same people
that's going to bring us the ministry of
truth that's right that's there that's
crazy they tried it and they were here's
what they were doing they've got these
organizations these non-profits that
have Government funding or meet with
people in government then they go the
nonprofits to Big Tech and say you got
to remove these people and big Tech says
oh no this is nonprofit giving us advice
it's just you know they're here for the
truth it's just a way the government
circumvents then they tried doing the
actual Ministry of Truth what were they
calling it like you know Department of
disinformation or some other nonsense
that's crazy any you go back and read
all the history books anybody is doing
all the sensory turned out to be the bad
guys yeah I knew yeah tendency towards
the US was censoring uh heavily in World
War II we had an office of censorship
yeah the issue is when you're not
allowed to express your opinion on
things right I guess back then in the
United States it was like don't talk
about where our boats are don't talk
about where our troops are going if you
hear someone say like I'm like because
what would happen is some dude would be
like mom being deployed I'm going to
this place and you go wow and then you
go tell somebody but it was never like
you couldn't tell somebody you didn't
like something it used to be that you
weren't allowed to incite like uh panic
in any way so the whole can't shout fire
in a crowded theater uh thing comes from
a guy that was trying to standing
outside and trying to tell people don't
sign up for the draft do not sign up for
the draft don't get drafted for World
War one it was and they were like you
can't do that that's illegal you know so
they arrested the guy went to the
Supreme Court they're like actually you
are allowed to tell people not because
you people panic about signing up for
the military right and that's total well
we're not in a war but but these emails
are specifically related to the covid-19
vaccine with specifically the White
House saying hey we don't like what
Tucker Carlson is saying about our
product that we're telling everyone to
take that we gave no liability for the
producers of and therefore we need to
take him down since this is a threat
against National Health and in reality
everything that Tucker Carlson was
warning about has essentially come true
and everything that the White House was
claiming uh has essentially been
officially debunked by many scientists
and many scientific studies that have
been coming out and proving it to be
absolutely false I'm optimistic Elon
Musk bought Twitter starts dumping all
the emails and evidence we got this
lawsuit from Louisiana and Missouri and
they're releasing more evidence so it
seems like the machine is is struggling
to keep up with this I wonder if the
White House is still emailing Twitter
though can you please do this just one
more time please give us a hit please
this was part of something this was part
of the Twitter files even after Elon
took over they were still asking the
people well now they're fired maybe
that's not really going on yeah right
but think about what do you guys think
the emo would look like
it's probably some setup on automation
yeah it's like input name right yeah
just like the Vice news articles when
they were throwing uh you know what uh
at the bar to pick up their latest yeah
they have they have an email where it
says greetings uh insert Facebook
employee here this is insert employee
user on on your platform insert username
is being racist and hateful and for this
we believe they've violated your rules
please ban insert username now right and
then they just copy and paste how
important is Elon Musk right now man
what he's doing that's why he's
traveling around with arm the guards and
stuff yeah which is amazing because all
he is is trying to protect Free Speech
which is the most important right we
have it's the most that's what made
America America free speech well they're
they're the operating see with the funny
fathers you know they'd have to draft
like Anonymous pamphlets and hand them
out so nobody knew where it was coming
from because they knew how important
Free Speech was and they were they were
fighting through the censorship musk
reminds me of Marche you guys know that
guy he's the French basically one of the
founding fathers of french guy he should
be on Mount Rushmore with the other guys
but he was like the guy that went as in
French spy for the French King he went
to England and then found out okay the
English are beating the hell out of the
Americans in the revolution so you go
back France and he'd Lie To The King The
French Kingdom yeah the Americans are
winning send money so then the French
got involved because of Beau marche's
lies he got them and then he was sending
his own personal money uh he set up a
fake company with this other guy in
Louisiana to send weapons and armor or
weapons and like uh outfits and stuff
but it was without him you know probably
would have been no American Revolution
wow because he wasn't an American
citizen right right Fox News had another
article a couple days ago that was
titled musk says U.S government demanded
Twitter suspend a quarter million
accounts including journalists according
to the Twitter file so 250 000 yes 250
000 accounts were uh were demanded to be
suspended by the US government that's a
lot of people sounds like that's a lot
of services and I bet probably everyone
in this room is on that list yeah I
wouldn't doubt it yeah I was blacklisted
on Facebook when I started uh crying
about uh covet when after the covet
stuff or no it's George Floyd and I was
like yo George Floyd had five chemicals
in his system he had fentanyl in a
system where let's talk about fentanyl
in his system behind the wheel of a car
driving high on fentanyl yeah let's talk
about that in Facebook but yeah we're in
a black guy yeah Kobe too right yeah
caffeine THC in his system yeah tobacco
you made this point way back when you
were saying that uh a dude high on
Fentanyl and meth a speedball behind the
the steering wheel of the car you got to
stop that person yeah some kids who
knows yeah yeah and you know what um you
know that whole incident when I first
saw it was hard to watch so I didn't
watch the whole video so I made myself
go back and watch it and I started to
analyze everything he said it was crazy
he started saying he couldn't breathe
before he even got to the ground he said
it when he was in the vehicle he was
overdosing and I was talking to a bunch
of police officers I run into when we're
doing our shows at airports and things
like that they said they find so many
people dead in jail from the same same
amount of drugs that that man had yeah
so I think it's a possibility he could
have died regardless of he'd wrote a
motorcycle well what got that cop
convicted yeah pretty sure because I
used to catch shoplifters and they told
us certain people old elderly you cannot
be on that chest right
um You got to handle them differently so
I'm sure cops have been trained if
somebody's telling you can't breathe you
don't have them even land on their
stomach that's what got him convicted
the lack of compassion for the guy if
you'd have wrote him over and he died
anyway he wouldn't be in jail all he had
to do is show that little amount of
compassion that's all he had to do yeah
yeah he was already handcuffed there was
no reason to have him sitting right
there I think it is flexing a little you
just Flex them yeah I mean George was
selection of the time no the cop was
flexing because you know at that time
cops was getting all these bad press and
I guess he was like in the moods like I
ain't gotta listen nobody I've been
trained to do this and he stopped
thinking well he got there later in
trouble yeah he did he was the last one
to get there right yeah I was like I
don't know don't care
he did like he knew George from working
together there's a bouncer in a bar was
that a real story came out I know I
don't know if it was real was it real
yeah yeah but look man there's people
that I've worked with I wouldn't
remember you know what I mean like I
worked at a company with 50 employees
you think I remember a single person
well he did George Floyd was like take
me out of the car please put me on the
ground I can't breathe I can't breathe
way before there's any kind of before
shove it even got there he said that
yeah and they said okay then Chauvin
shows up and he had Fenton on a system I
mean absolutely the guy was out of his
hand I should have been arrested for
being behind the wheel of a car on
fentanyl yeah just this body reaction
the way he was acting it was like no
grown man that's not how I act like a
big dude he's just saying like I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die he was like saying he
thought he was gonna die before anything
kicked off yeah a while well anyway
Facebook sensors didn't like that this
piece of honest observation yeah
and uh I don't like centralized systems
because like you said Luke was it 200
250 000 accounts yeah that's gonna
happen forever if we leave our social
media networks in centralized systems
it's already happening on uh Facebook on
YouTube on Instagram on WhatsApp all of
those other things on Tick Tock three
times um we came this close to getting
banned on Facebook what's your what is
it for huh what did they try to get
speech they called us States we had a
million followers on uh Tick Tock link
it's deleted like it was nothing Tick
Tock yeah so you went to zero three
different times come back yeah not not
try again and I got like four I think
300 but I'm on my last strike so I just
stopped posting is it what's getting
what's getting you banned on Tick Tock
just my same videos I post on YouTube
Facebook same videos we gotta take them
down they say it's hate speech I posted
a video of a transgender female which is
a biological male breastfeed no
transgender woman yeah transgender woman
sorry yeah because transgender female is
Who Wants To Be A Man so like yeah
someone born with the yeah no parts so
she's had a breastfeed
I got up and and I come back to theater
I'm like what the [ __ ] and I said that's
the that's the whole video she's right
there trying to breastfeed it didn't
kill him what the [ __ ] you got banned
for that yeah yep it got removed thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time